le ministre de la santé annonce a
déclaré en fin de semaine dernière que
l'allemagne négocierait son propre
approvisionnement en ce public vers une
fois le feu vert de l'agencé européenne
des médicaments obtenus
si l'allemagne doit négocier un accord
propre parce que le programme d'achat
commun européen ne s'applique pas aux
vaccins speaker pour le moment a
également suscité des commentaires en
france selon le ministre français des
affaires étrangères il s'agit d'un coup
de publicité visant à rassurer les
marchés locaux avant il y as c'est vrai
des élections en septembre et pour lui
yann c span fait de la politique il a
également affirmé qu'il n'écarterait
aucun vaccin en fonction de son origine
disons qu'un bon vaccin est un bon
vaccin
concernant le sésame de l'agencé
européenne du médicament les tirs du val
saint astier a débuté le 5 mars et
devrait durer peut-être même jusqu'à fin
mai s'il maintient le feu vert il pourra
bien sûr être utilisé dans toutes
ignorées